[Music]
the stars of my the Shah is of our dear
saviors birth
[Music]
and said
to leave me and the soul
[Music]
yeah
we rejoice
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Divac
[Music]
when Christ was born
[Music]
the
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
in crisis
[Music]
diva
[Music]
Almighty
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to certified country I'm
Sophia lacy you just watched Danielle
Bradbery singing oh holy night stunning
thank you absolutely beautiful
yeah what does that song mean to you um
I I think it's probably one of my
favorite Christmas songs I always grew
up listening to it and I love hearing
all the versions and I think I heard one
of my favorite artists Carrie Underwood
do it and I'm like it's just such a
beautiful song yeah absolutely well
thank you for singing it for us thank
you for being here cool now if you guys
are still looking for stocking stuffers
may I just say that Danielle's new album
I don't believe we've met makes a good
one yes cuz relations on anyway thank
you are you just like riding high right
now
oh yeah I'm fighting time I have been
just non-stop but it's like it's the
greatest busy that you could be it's
been four years since I put out an album
so it's been pretty exciting for me and
just my management and my team and we're
just like okay finally we can release
this now it's time yes would you ever do
a holiday album or something like that
of course yeah when the time's right
obviously I would love to do Christmas
album I love Christmas it's just so
happy so what are you gonna be doing
this Christmas um I usually I go home
for the holidays which is nice in Texas
okay and I go home and just spend time
with my family and just hang out I love
going home for Christmas amazing have
such a great time thank you so much for
being here thank you thank you guys so
much for watching if this is your first
time with us please subscribe to
Entertainment Tonight on YouTube we will
be back each and every Friday with a
brand new episode
[Music]